Quincy it's so awesome to have you and
and just on a personal note for uh for
folks who may not know I've been writing
on free code camp for I think over a
year now and Quincy was uh gracious
enough to to help support the Julie
ecosystem by
um letting me publish some articles
there which have uh had a huge impact in
region
um it's been awesome to see sort of that
um your your community that you've built
uh be able to learn about Julia and some
of the things that that our community
are doing
yeah absolutely uh thank you very much
it's been just an honor having you share
your expertise with the community and
thank you to Conrad II for that very
kind introduction um I'm thrilled to
join here over at Pi data uh a lot of my
friends are like oh you're gonna be a
pie data that's awesome so uh you know
the refutation precedes
the big event and I'm thrilled uh I'm
thrilled to be here so thank you to both
of you gentlemen and thank you to
everybody who's involved in organizing
the event
yeah no we we appreciate you being here
and it's uh it's definitely a lot of
work but these are a ton of fun so uh
we're happy to put them on
yeah well kind of I will answer as many
questions as I can uh sure yeah and I
just want to like be very candid and say
that like I started free code Camp eight
years ago but I am one of many many
people that makes all of this possible
uh there are
like more than a thousand
prolific contributors from the past year
for example like we just compiled the
2022 top contributors and a whole lot of
Open Source contributors a whole lot of
people
uh of course writing tutorials about
Julia and other topics
um and then of course uh we have a whole
lot of people that are helping translate
those tutorials into a variety of world
languages Japanese Spanish uh Swahili
Ukrainian uh and then of course we also
have a whole lot of people that are just
being extremely helpful in the community
hanging out on the Forum answering other
people's questions and and then of
course the open source projects
themselves devdocs.io freecodecamp.org
developerquiz.org uh code radio all the
different kind of satellite things that
we're doing so uh I just wanted to take
a moment to thank those people and
recognize them and I don't want anybody
to think like I'm just like getting
everything done myself because I'm just
a very small piece in the puzzle yeah
and Quincy maybe can you take us back to
eight years ago when you first created
free code cabin and sort of looking and
reflecting back on what you've been able
to achieve in those last eight years and
um like was the ambition this from the
gecko like you wanted this massive
Global Community where you have things
translated into link into multiple
languages and billions of people reading
this content or was it a much smaller
vision and it's just sort of
um yeah taken off in the way that it was
yeah I mean like I would
you know like this this is greatly
exceeded even my most ambitious crazy
idea of what could be accomplished like
I just published the number yesterday
and uh people spent the equivalent of 8
000 years using free Coke camp in 2022.
the like the equivalent of like having 8
000 people at any given point using free
code camp and all I wanted to do was
just make it a little easier for people
to learn to code so it wasn't so
ambiguous and so lonely uh so yeah of
course I'm like over the moon it won't
be accomplished and I have to pinch
myself every day
um because it feels like you know this
is all a dream I'm just gonna wake up
and you know uh have to start from
scratch again as anybody who's created
the project knows like the the biggest
challenge in the world is getting people
to even care about your projects and so
a lot of the early projects I built were
all they were all focused on technology
education I've always been interested in
that area
um and I before technology education I
worked as a School director and as a
teacher teaching English mostly to
students who are coming to the US to get
master's degrees and needed to be able
to pass the TOEFL or some of these other
standardized tests
um and so I've always been very
interested in specifically adult
education
and uh I think that there are a lot of
people doing very exciting great work in
helping kids but the adults kind of like
it
left aside in many cases people just say
oh well you can just go work as a
janitor you can go work as uh you know
like work at Taco Bell where I work for
a few years and and like so I know what
kind of like desperate like unfulfilling
work it can be to work in in retail or
work
um you know like stocking shelves
overnight at a grocery store or I even
work construction for a while like uh
not like like those those can be great
jobs and there can be a career
progression but a lot of jobs
you know it's just kind of like the
moment that your employer can automate
away your job they will without any sort
of hesitation right
um so I wanted to make it a little
easier for people to be able to get into
what I could what I call like the the
creative like knowledge worker type
roles that increasingly require computer
skills
um and knowledge of math computer
science and programming specifically so
um I wanted to make it a little easier
for people to do that so after creating
a bunch of projects that nobody cared
about nobody used uh trying to get them
on uh product hunt or trying to like you
know show them on Reddit to people like
hey check out this thing I built you
know like like dealing with that
indifference that pretty much everybody
feels when they're trying to get a
project out there and get get some
initial level of Interest
um I just kind of sat down one weekend
and I was like let's strip out all the
complexity let's make it as simple as
possible let's come up with a very
explicit name free code Camp it's like
totally unambiguous right and uh pretty
much regardless of what language people
speak if they went to high school and
they have high school level English
they're probably going to be able to
understand what frico camp means right
they're probably gonna be able to spell
it so um
yeah like I just stood it up with the
most simple curriculum just a single
linear curriculum and to this day it's
really just a single linear curriculum
and a whole lot of supplemental
resources but uh I'm sorry if I'm like
giving the most long-winded answer I
want to make sure we get to everybody's
questions but basically it was just the
desire to help people not have to
because I was 31 when I really started
programming and I was just working as a
School director and I needed to automate
a lot of the things I was doing day to
day and that's where I got interested in
Python and uh you know using Excel
spreadsheets like trying to automate
things using that automating things with
this Windows tool called Auto hotkey
where I could like program it to click
on all the government forms for me so I
could like just kind of like all time
over grab the data I'll die back fill it
in the form and it would do that and I
could get up from my desk and go help
students instead of sitting there like
you know clicking on things and web
forms and stuff and so that was the
origins of my programmer skills and then
I was able to just like hang out at the
hacker space and go to a lot of
hackathons around California and and
build up my my programming shops that
way uh and then I got a job as a
software engineer about nine months
after uh learning after leaving my job
and just learning the code full time uh
just like sitting around the house like
going through library books going
through uh free online courses like uh
Stanford has some really good database
courses algorithms courses
um
I managed to get the job and that was
when the real learning started so our
goal has always been to like help people
get that first job and then support them
after they've gotten their first job as
they continue to progress with their
skills and I have this very like some
people may say it's overly simplistic
but this perception of like a typical
career progression might be like you
just get a job as like some sort of web
development or doing something like that
and you get your programming chops while
you're going back and you're relearning
all your stats and other mathematics and
then you can continue to progress into
like
data science machine learning type roles
and or if you want you can get into like
security devops like they're all these
different progressions but I really do
believe that like web development is
kind of like
the shortest path to getting paid and
actually having some responsibility on
the team so free code curriculum if you
look at it is extremely linear it's like
let's learn some HTML let's learn some
CSS let's learn some uh Linux command
line let's learn how SQL works you know
and and like let's go through this very
clear progression to ramp you up toward
a job it's kind of like the shortest
path to a job so to this day that's
that's still in the curriculum you'll
see it's extremely pragmatic and uh we
try it's not like the Senate from the
Ivory Tower it's very much like bottom
up from talking to hiring managers and
just trying to understand what work
needs to be done so people can go out
and do that
yeah Quincy it sounds like you gave
yourself the original
um like you made your own boot camp to
begin with basically when you started
full-time those those nine months which
is super cool and and
um also sounds like you sort of maybe
placed that trail
um inadvertently for a lot of people who
now it's it's sort of a more traditional
path when people go and boot camp
instead of going and like doing a
four-year computer science degree which
is also something that free code Camp is
sort of working on so we'll talk about
that later but I wanted to ask one one
other follow-up question and I'll pass
it to Conrad
um that initial curriculum that you
developed
um the the sort of simple MVP version
like did that did that originally
initially get traction or did you have
to sort of build off of that or what was
the sort of State when you put it out in
the world and then were people showing
up or know what was yeah
that's a great question and all my other
projects have been crickets when you put
it up but Franco Camp was different like
with it like I built it like the MVP
within a weekend and stood it up and
started tweeting about it and by the end
of the weekend people were like in the
chat room hanging out and a day or two
later it was on the front of Hacker News
and like so there was that critical mass
like it you know you never know when
you're building projects your next
project might be the big breakthrough or
or even the current project there might
just be like some minor tweak that you
make that that you know makes all the
difference for us it was having that
simple linear curriculum and having it
be very you know free obviously free is
the most powerful word in marketing it's
the most powerful like people just don't
want to whip out their credit cards even
if it's like a dollar right like people
really like being able to just use
things freely and and any suspicion of
the organization kind of like dissipates
if if the if it's completely free and we
were very transparent about like user
data and stuff like that to this day the
only personal identifying information we
collect from people is their email
address
um just so we can authenticate them and
and track their progress right and then
if they want they can add other you know
information and populate their profile
but uh but yeah we wanted to
basically just make it extremely
approachable and that curriculum like
for whatever reason uh maybe it was
because I struggled through all this
stuff myself and I knew what courses
were good like Stanford's CS course was
really good
um and there were some other uh you know
moocs basically calling moocs I don't
know if anybody knows where the mooc is
massive online open course
um massively open yeah anyway mooc uh
there were like a whole bunch of those
and I was basically strapped those
together and they were like I think it
was like 14 Mooks or something
constituted the original curriculum and
people would just self-report like I
finished this and then we started
rolling out the interactive like
validation where you could get kind of a
flow state where you're like all right
I'm developed I'm like
coding in the browser this passes I know
that I've done the correct thing I
advance to the next one and and that was
really like that interactivity has
really been her Hallmark ever since it's
just actually having a valuation
criteria and not relying on the person
to
manually verify like themselves like it
looks like I got this right okay I'm
gonna mark it done man move on like it
just removes a lot of the ambiguity but
yes sorry for the very long answer but
but yeah like the the curriculum itself
just took off uh pretty pretty much
immediately
huh thank you uh and so I I guess uh I
just just
um a quick thought like I really like uh
how you talked about uh how you're uh
taking more uh adult education stuff and
making sure that that part is covered I
really do believe that Tech is the great
equalizer uh especially coming from uh
myself uh having not started out uh as
you know immediately as a programmer
um but so you also talked about you know
for example like uh for this uh for a
free code Camp uh you knew it was
immediately different it was immediately
uh uh uh different from the other
projects that you've done because you
know like a day or two later it was on
Hacker News uh and stuff like that I was
wondering uh you know I could like like
were there any like really memorable or
like notable milestones and achievements
uh uh a free code camp that you could
talk about and also maybe more
quantitatively do you guys have any uh
you know specific metrics uh or or kpis
that you now use to track free code camp
and inform any decisions that you guys
make as as a group I guess now right
yeah that's an excellent question I
apologize if I didn't hear 100 of it
because my son wanted me to like be the
level on Mario Odyssey For Me often
walked in with the switch like Oh Daddy
um but uh what I was gonna uh to answer
your question to the best of my ability
maybe I can restate your question and uh
anything that was like a big
breakthrough for us quantitatively that
could be Quantified
um the I think the biggest breakthrough
for us early on was that people started
getting jobs and uh we set up like a
LinkedIn Alumni network and people can
add their certifications when they claim
them and then that made it relatively
easy for us to go in just within
linkedin's UI and see okay like these
people like it shows where are people
working at and if you go to free code
camps LinkedIn Alumni Association you'll
see a lot of people are working on like
um working at Google Amazon Microsoft
Apple like all the big tech companies
Alibaba 10 cent and then
um you know uh even even some uh African
tech companies uh and then a lot of
people have like odesk or not oh desk
anymore is like not freelancer.com
there's like a newer um they like all
merged and created like this this new
website but a lot of people uh do work
on that like as contractors and and
um and then you see just a lot of people
that have created their own
consultancies but
seeing people actually getting jobs
especially you know as you know
thousands of people tens of thousands of
people
um now currently like the Alumni
Association which has more than a
million followers but they it officially
it has like 200
some thousand alumni who have earned a
certification and at least one
certification
um just seeing like where they work and
what they're doing and all that stuff is
it's really inspiring
um and so once we saw that that was when
we knew okay it's working like it's not
like some hypothetical it's not like a
bunch of people like wishfully thinking
like uh oh if I make through this maybe
I'll be able to get a job like it became
a proven path to getting a job and at
that moment that's when we really
started to get like serious like like I
had a lot of engineering managers and
people like that like oh yeah like
people started taking free cocaine
seriously because they started seeing
people who went through a free code Camp
being able to get through you know the
Google job interview battery things like
that right
um so that is one metric that we think
is really important is just like the
proportion of people and the total
amount of people that uh get jobs but
some other data that we use
um for each of the challenges on the
free cocaine curriculum we track how
long it takes somebody to complete it so
we have like average completion time and
we use that metric to like identify
potential bottlenecks in the curriculum
where like this isn't sufficiently well
explained because people should be able
to complete this challenge in like two
minutes or less right and they're taking
an average in performance what's going
on with this can we reword this can we
break this down into smaller bits so we
use data that way
um and and that's like another big thing
but I just published an article like
less than 24 hours ago about our 2022
usage statistics and and it kind of
breaks down like the usage of all these
different uh we have the four pillars of
freeco Camp which it wasn't your
question but I can tell you real quick
it's the Forum where people help one
another it's the publication where uh
Logan and the other uh developers
publish uh tutorials uh and and just
kind of like hey I built this project
here's how you can build it like code
along and home type things and then we
have the uh Community YouTube channel
where we'll publish full-length courses
um and then we have of course the main
Core Curriculum uh so those four pillars
and I kind of break down the usage
growth of those over the past few years
as well
um and everything else for us is just
learner minutes that's like the metric
we care about we don't really care about
like retention like how many people
actually complete the entire program
because nobody completes the entire
program it's too long like you could
easily go ahead and get a job once
you're like even a third of the way
through the curriculum the idea is that
you can keep going back to the
curriculum and keep expanding your
skills over a longer period of time and
uh and obviously nobody can complete all
the extracurricular
courses because we publish like I don't
know 10 15 20 some something I published
like 50 hours worth of coursework no
nobody's gonna be able to go through
like our Matlab course and then shift
gears and do our flutter course and like
they're just supplemental resource so we
just focus on the absolute amount of
time that people are learning and that's
our kind of like uh way of like
generousizing usage
um so we can just understand like use
Canucks usefulness so that's how we kind
of like like okay people are using it
that's good I don't know like that may
sound unsophisticated or overly
reductive but
that's how we've been doing it and I'm
I'm well I welcome any feedback or
thoughts that you all have about how we
what might be interesting what insights
might be interesting I think uh that's a
it's it's a very good point I think uh
you know uh just uh the workshops and
learning is only the first step right so
so the next step is actually you know
getting the job learning on the job and
like career progression afterwards right
so that's definitely the most important
uh metric to track uh just very quickly
uh we have a lot of questions
um uh so I'm just gonna ask a very quick
follow-up question but yeah it is uh you
know I didn't want this to be all data
point so I wanted to also ask you you
know what was your most memorable uh you
know when did you decide oh my God free
code Camp you know like we made it right
it's a thing now yeah I mean like uh
there's not any one moment that that
comes to mind I
just had like I mean like this this is
kind of weird and surreal but like if I
just open my inbox uh there will be
people like hey I got this job here or
like it's just like constantly people
talk people people who have people who
are completely blind for example who
have like substantial disabilities that
they're living with and they're still
able to go out and use their skills to
get jobs and things like that that was
that was like a big uh moment for me is
hearing about those kinds of stories
yeah that's so cool and it it almost
sounds like the the success has been
there I'm sure there's been bumps along
the road but like from the very get-go
like as soon as as soon as it was on the
front page of Hacker News when you first
announced it and I'd imagine it's
um yeah it's been sort of a steady
rocket ship for the last for the last
eight years which is super cool to see
but wanted to to drop over to one of the
audience questions
um which I think is is super relevant
um Francesco was asking how do you deal
with the fact that there are so many
resources right now
um that can be super overwhelming for
for beginners
um who are who are trying to learn how
to program
yeah I mean that's an excellent question
and that's actually one of the the
reasons that free cocaine exists is
because we wanted to have a single
linear curriculum that represents like I
said like kind of like a
a clear shortest path to that first
developer job uh and if you look at the
free cocaine curriculum we don't have
any electives we don't have any
branching you know logic or anything
like oh if you've already done this skip
this and go to here like it is just like
start here and you can skip anything you
want and keep moving downward but but
you shouldn't be like jumping up and
down and stuff like that right like
um
like every single part of the free
cocaine curriculum you can skip it if
you build the projects that are required
to earn that certification you can you
can get that certification regardless of
whether you did any of the actual
instructional content it's just a quick
evaluation criteria so that makes it
easier for people that are intermediates
to come in there and just quickly
progress to where they you know to the
Goldilocks zone where it's it's
um it's hard enough for them and they're
actually learning new stuff instead of
just reviewing uh so you know we're as
guilty as anybody of just inundating the
world with free learning resources
um and uh
what we do is we do that with a caveat
that like hey this is a good reference
but if you need to learn the
fundamentals you should just use the
Core curriculum
um that would be my humble advice uh and
again
there's so many resources there's so
many different curricula like you know
Harvard cs50 for example if you just go
through that you'll get a really good
foundation and computer science Concepts
um you know but you don't necessarily
need to do that first or you can do that
in tandem with using free cocaine but
free cocam represents if at any point
you're like this is too complicated just
you know go to free cooking we will make
it as simple as we can
I love that and and maybe one more this
goes back to something you were talking
about before as far as what some of the
pillars of free code camp but something
that was has always been very
interesting to me
um and obviously it works in some sense
because the free code Camp YouTube is is
huge and has a massive reach and it gets
a ton of Engagement from from your
community and from people who want to
learn how to program in general but
um I had always imagined that for like
educational content it made more sense
to chunk things down into small little
pieces but free codecamp actually
releases like some of the courses that
you put on YouTube are like 24-hour Long
YouTube videos which I didn't even know
was possible sometimes until I saw you
all doing it so what's the thought
behind having it be like one giant
um video instead of sort of breaking it
up into smaller chunks or are people not
supposed to be consuming it on YouTube
and it's like broken up on the website
or something like that
I mean uh first of all how do we get
like such long videos on the YouTube our
longest one is I think 37 now we have a
37 hour flutter course
um and we do it through compression
tricks
um with compression you can get you can
get like uh
25 hour 4K I think that the Harvard
course is uh 4K we've published some
other course that are 4K as well
um but uh the reasoning behind just
publishing the entire course is because
first of all people could see what you
see is what you get right it's not like
oh okay oh look this like oh actually
you gotta pay to get the rest of the
course or um like any of those kind of
like Shenanigans like you can see it's a
25 hour course right there in the
timestamp and it simplifies things other
thing is it's very easy to share you
just copy the like the address bar and
you throw that in your text message to
your friend be like hey check out this
course you know um and it's also very
easy to bookmark right um so it's just
the Simplicity uh and the accessibility
of having everything in one video and
then you just use timestamps and you get
like that broken up bar at the bottom
and people who do want to skip around
can skip around but they're skipping
around on the same video so they don't
have to worry uh also if somebody wants
to download the video we have a lot of
people that will like go to like an
internet cafe or something in parts of
the world where data is more expensive
they'll get on some Wi-Fi they can
download the entire video and then they
can watch it that way over the course of
the next week or two
um so it's 100 just for convenience and
accessibility
um for learners
no that makes a ton of sense that would
be something where the metrics would be
really interesting to look at and see
like do you do people like see a 24 hour
long video and say oh that's you know
it's a little too scary for me versus
like you know a five minute video maybe
I'll dive in and get started because it
seems uh more approachable than some of
those long uh 24-hour videos yeah and
that's an important point is
um
a lot of people do what's called
information grazing we're like oh I want
to learn about this and there's a
there's a very good chance Channel
called fireship it's just those like C
plus plus in three minutes or whatever
right and it's a cool video I'm not
criticizing them or anything but you
can't learn things in three minutes like
nobody thinks you can learn that they're
they're just it's almost kind of comical
that like we're gonna give you the most
superficial possible you know overview
and then you know RC plus course might
be like 12 hours or something like that
and it's just the basics
um something like that right so
um
I think that uh we want people to
realize that okay this is a serious
course like this is we're not oversell
like the biggest problem I think on the
internet with like people think that
they can get away with like over
promising and under delivering and that
that'll be a viable strategy long term
but it isn't all what it does is it just
breeds kind of like suspicion that
everybody's just like
trying to trick you into like like oh
this isn't actually that comprehensive
like you're it's very easy as a learner
to essentially learn the same
fundamental stuff like over and over
right like you could spend 24 hours
watching one hour beginner tutorials on
the same exact topic and just relearn
that same stuff or you can go really
deep with a longer course so part of the
reason we have these really long courses
is we're emphasizing no this is like
really deep like we're giving the topic
sufficient breadth uh or like sufficient
room uh for you to really like learn
something and to really code along at
home and build a substantial project
rather than just building like a quick
hello world type proof of concept
foreign
[Music]
cool
um I was also just wondering uh just
building on the uh a comment from the uh
audience
um in terms of your like relationship
with some of the other uh resources and
uh platforms out there like like or like
sub personally at least when when you
know when I've been uh you know chatting
with friends and talking to them about
like hey here's how you can learn uh
data science right like I try to heavily
uh utilize all the available resources
out there right so like you know we
might have our own thing but we might
also just say like hey but like if you
don't know this thing this other like
free like uh open source resource there
there is like super good right uh so so
I like I don't want to re like reinvent
the wheel right like uh like like why
don't you take a look at that right uh
is this something that you guys do at
all or yeah yeah so um what we do we're
probably going to create our own course
on practically every topic eventually
especially if we can get like like the
tensorflow team has has been giving us
grants to develop courses
um for example so we're going to cover
like a lot of those ml like I know a lot
of uh creators like uh Tina Huang Kenji
like people on
um that are on like kind of developer
YouTube essentially
um and they're individual creators and
they're creating really uh they'll
create uh shorter videos and then maybe
they'll have a course on like udemy or
something like that like we can't
reproduce a lot of what they're doing in
terms of the specific angle like a lot
of what makes YouTube great is the
individual instructor
um and like their particular approach
toward explaining something or their
particular project ideas that they they
incorporate and things like that so I
want to make it clear that even though
we're hitting a lot of these topics I
want to like there is no One-Stop shop
really for anything uh certainly not for
like learning resources and I do
encourage people to like try everything
out there uh I what I can say is like we
don't have control over the quality of
other people's
um courses but we do have direct control
over the quality of free code case
courses so at some point like
if you want it done right it makes sense
to just do it yourself so that that's
kind of our philosophy is like we want
to encourage people to use these uh
resources and we all talk like like uh I
talk about all these creators and they
they probably talk to one another as
well uh and and we're all just trying to
basically like education YouTube is this
very very tiny slice of YouTube as a
whole especially technology education
YouTube and because it's it's growing so
quickly like I often tell people when
the pie is growing really fast it makes
sense to to focus on like like it
doesn't make sense to fight for like
tiny like additional like degrees on the
pie
um you know just just focus on trying to
get I
um so so it's it's very collaborative
and fun and there's a lot of crossovers
things like that
um on YouTube so that would be the main
thing I I'd emphasize is like nobody's
saying like just use freako camp like
even we're not saying that like we're
saying there's no One-Stop shopping you
should make use of all the different
resources out there
um yes uh and I I think uh definitely uh
the tech field moves so fast right so so
you know just ever like like everyone is
scrambling to just uh like each every
single uh piece of uh like a workshop or
a piece of material is definitely
scrambling even just to be stay current
and relevant and there there's a lot of
Maintenance and update needed uh so
maybe it's time to talk about uh you
know
um plans for the future you know like
like where do you see uh uh free code
Camp going like how do you make sure
that
uh things as things stay relevant
um yeah
well um free code games open source and
uh one of the things we do with
interactive curricula is it's very easy
to just go in and update a code snippet
to like adopt like a best practice or
update some tests to to address like a
common alternate way of like coding
something
um so what because there's this Maxim in
open source uh with enough eyeballs all
bugs are shallow they'll get fixed
eventually by some well-meaning uh open
source contributor so
a lot of the curriculum is just I liken
it too like I took some extremely Jagged
you know rocks that I found on the
ground and put them into this rock
tumbler that is the open source
community over the years the curriculum
is like kind of like
become polished Stones
um and the same thing goes for whenever
we introduce new curricula for example
the new relational database
certification or um some of the upcoming
uh data science courses that we're
developing uh but a lot of it is just
a desire and a willingness to be
corrected by the community and to have
things be improved uh and it's not just
us doing it again we've got hundreds of
Open Source contributors in the past
year that have gone and made a PR on
GitHub and so I I think a big part of it
is just
you know opening yourself up to
criticism and critique and and having
people come in and say like oh this is
like a deprecated
method or like oh this this entire
approach like uh I think it was like the
the creator of Redux was uh they never
wrong if he was like don't use the Redux
anymore well our curriculum still
technically uses Redux we're working on
like taking out with the new version but
like uh that's something that we're
actively trying to do is adapt
uh or adopt uh new emerging best
practices and adapt as you know the
tools change over time the tools and the
general preferences because a lot of it
is not necessarily like a lot of these
kind of circular like
there will be conventions that you know
oh we're going to use this certain
approach that's in Vogue from 1970s
instead of this 1990s approach that is
no longer in both but that 1990s
approach May ultimately be back in Vogue
later but a lot of it is just convention
it doesn't really matter what's right so
much as like what is likely to be
understood by your colleagues and what
is likely to be seen as a sensible
solution if you're in a whiteboard
coding interview right
um so a lot of it is just us like
adapting to The ever-changing Meta
yeah and and going back to the the
second part of Conrad's question around
the future of a freedco camp I know I
saw the announcement
um it had to have been a few months ago
now around creating like a University
degree program I'm not sure if I'm fully
grasp what what that all entails so it
seems really cool and it seems like it's
this uh dream situation where people can
get an education without having to pay
through all the Ivory Tower stuff that
we we know that traditional education
has
um so can you can you dive into the
details about like what that what it
actually means in practice for people
yeah absolutely so I've always been a
big fan of universities even though I
think they're overpriced for the most
part you know I like the university so
much I went to back to grad school and
uh
I feel like everybody should be able to
get a University degree and I feel like
ideally
should be completely socioeconomically
blind in the sense that anyone who wants
to invest the time and energy in
completing the coursework should be able
to get the degree uh and I don't like
the notion of like fees and enrollment
and application and like oh your your
room is no longer current you have to
reapply or oh we can't accept these
transfer credits like all this stuff
right like uh so what what I set out to
do like I mean in my mind I've always
wanted felt University should be free
but I knew if I came out in 2011 when I
was just some guy that was learning the
code like nobody would it wouldn't have
any credibility if I said we're going to
create a free University degree nobody
would take it seriously because it is a
multi-decade Endeavor essentially like
uh it's gonna take us probably like six
or seven years just to develop the
coursework for the University degree
program but we are developing uh 40 uh
full-length university courses that they
constitute you you know 90 Plus hours of
coursework most of that being Labs
lectures and then a final exam
for each of the 40 courses so
um what we're doing is if you pull up
that particular
announcement it lists out the specific
courses and so it starts with a
Associates an associate of science in
mathematics and in that you basically
recap all of high school math and then
you go into you know stats calc
um you know uh all the different like
linear algebra stuff that's really
useful in programming and machine
learning
um and so you're going to complete those
along with General Ed courses like
epistemology we call it philosophy of
knowledge and uh you know like ethical
thought things like that so so it's very
much like a similar to
how education traditionally was before
the 1900s where everybody started the
exact same you know Trivium and
quadrivium and got a liberal arts degree
um and then they got out everybody had
the same basic skill set right math
um science and understanding like the
Arts and things like that right
um understanding rhetoric understanding
uh uh logic and reason
um things like that so we we definitely
tip our head very heavily to
that educational tradition that's a
thousand years old
um there are no electives so everybody
just goes through the exact same 20
courses
after completing those they get an
associate of science in mathematics then
we have another 20 courses that
basically just Stacks right on top of it
that that focuses more on uh computer
science software engineering and
ultimately machine learning uh there are
going to be several machine learning
Focus courses and there are security
focused courses
um which so what we did was we did a
cross analysis of the top 20 computer
science programs in the United States
Carnegie Mellon Harvey Mudd
Stanford MIT
um you know all these schools Caltech
and we looked at what they were teaching
and we basically just drew a best fit
line through them and we're like okay
we're going to teach the most
conventional degree imaginable but it's
going to be free the key differentiator
is it's completely free it's completely
self-paced and there are some uh
tuition-free degree programs you can get
like uh University the people's doing
good work uh Western Governors
University is doing good work but
there's still some Financial costs
associated with it you're still going to
spend like 10 15 20 000 earning one of
those degrees potentially depending on
how long it takes with free cocamp the
idea is it could take you 10 years to
complete it but you're never going to
spend a dime once you've completed a
certain amount you'll formally
matriculate and you'll earn your degree
um and that's that right and then so
once we've finished all the coursework
gotten the students enrolled started
Gathering outcome data and all this then
we can go through the process of
accreditation which is a long process
it's an expensive process but basically
it involves having a lot of phds from
other universities come and like look at
your coursework and
essentially audit it to see whether they
think it's good and look at your
outcomes data
um so our goal is eventually have this
these degrees have the same type of
accreditation that other universities
have
um but again be completely free that's
that's everything free that's the core
differentiator here
yeah and Quincy can you elaborate on
maybe from your background in the
education space like why can you not
just take like for example you have the
the you know cs50 classroom David
um you know he he's accredited he
teaches at Harvard that's an accredited
program why can we not just take these
classes that already exist out there and
I know obviously it would be awesome if
you know to have them remade and more
accessible in some way but why can't
they just be repackaged if a university
approves that and then like
automatically accredited yeah the same
the cs50 online
um is the same cs50 if you were sitting
in the classroom listening to David live
right um the main challenge first of all
is there could be like some dependencies
like some circular dependencies like
this course assumes you know algebra
like really well and oh you haven't
taken another course so like okay go
grab a novice or textbook figure it out
like when you get
courses from different universities like
even if you go to like like the
university I went to which was uh
Oklahoma the University of Central
Oklahoma right it's like this small
state school cost me like a thousand
bucks a year to go back in 2000
um and uh yeah like
it was a thousand bucks a semester it
wasn't thousands so three thousand
because I always did the summer
semesters
um it was really cheap though like I'm
not complaining but uh but like that
like you even in between courses at that
same University I would find like the
teaching style would be completely
different the teacher would presume I'd
take in other courses that weren't
actually part of the formal curriculum
you go talk to the department chair like
it's kind of chaotic because every
Professor wants to put their
fingerprints on their individual course
and they get to choose their textbook
sometimes it's textbook that they have
an author so they're getting like money
from textbook sales as a result of
having University students take their
course there's all these conflicting
like like Academia is kind of a
um you know it's not like a extremely
easy to pin down place it's got a
thousand years of History universities
have these extremely powerful professors
that have tenure that they kind of have
a high degree of freedom and can
basically just book administrative uh
decisions administrators might make
decisions that professors you know
rightfully disagree with because they're
putting like institutional profitability
above pedagogy things like that right so
um you can't just grab like Omakase cell
like all these different things and like
slap them together and you can there's a
so it's called open source Society
University we started by a free code
Camp along ossu and uh it's basically
like hey we figured out which courses
usually taking one sequence that are
available on Coursera and edx and all
these other programs right that's cool
and then you just hang out on the
Discord and essentially everybody goes
through the course I don't know if
people actually complete all four years
of that but even if you did you wouldn't
have an institution that gives you the
degree and frankly the degree is what
gets the HR person to check the box when
they're like using whatever software to
like go through these degrees in in HR
people you know at a company that might
spend six seconds is the average from a
few years ago I wrote about this uh
they'll spend an average of six seconds
looking at a resume and if you don't
have a college degree it's quite
possible they'll spend zero seconds
looking at it because they'll just
filter you out for all the talk at you
know big tech companies about not caring
about University degrees people that
don't have University degrees are still
greatly underrepresented and that might
change over time but we're not we're not
going to wait and see we're going to do
something about it and make it to where
anybody can get a degree so that's kind
of a little bit of a digression from
your question which is like why can't
you just take these moocs that are
already really high quality are we going
to find a teacher who's as skilled as
David Miller to teach computer science
no like he's like the world renowned
like greatest computer design teacher in
the world right like
um his course is the most popular mooc
of all time it's the most popular course
at Harvard right like we're not going to
be able to do it but we are going to do
a good job in a way that like
interoperates with all the other math
courses that preceded and everything and
we're going to cover similar topics
um we're all drawing from the same you
know
tradition of
thousands of years of math and 100 you
know Decades of computer science right
you know what's uh very interesting I
realized uh um your your view on how to
design the curriculum is a very
opinionated right like you know uh
currently you know a simple linear
program right for the potent the college
stuff you know know you like to
everybody that does the same thing and
so it really reminds me of uh the the
center python the pythonic way right
like simple is vertically complicated
there should only be one way like we're
going to be very opinionated about how
this should go
um but one thing I did notice actually
is uh for the code Camp you know it's
it's a one linear thing but you expect
people to maybe uh uh uh like drop off
or you know like choose choose which
parts they want to do uh but for college
that would be slightly different right
because now like you are going to be
mandating them to actually you know do
the whole thing right
do the exams so uh you know the exam
might only take an hour and you're like
okay I already know so I'm just gonna
sit for the exam you don't have to pay a
fee to take the exam you just take it as
many times as you want and if you're
hubris gets the best of you you just go
back hit the books and then try again
right so so like there's always we
always want to have a release valve for
people who feel like they don't need it
whether that's true or not uh you know
confidence is the problem feedback is
the cure
um let people knock themselves up right
uh that's kind of been our philosophy
but we don't want to force anybody to
sit through a bunch of videos uh and and
do a bunch of labs we want them to be
able to just if they can demonstrate
Mastery just keep moving
yeah I wanted to jump to another
question from the audience which is it
should be a nice quick one
um but you mentioned something about a
data science curriculum that's being
worked on it I'm not sure if this is
related to this or not or if you can
comment on this yeah absolutely so so
those courses that we're developing uh
on like you know uh reinforcement
learning and
um supervised unsupervised transfer
learning like things like that that is
all going to be part of the degree
program so those are more lecture
focused they're going to have
interactive Labs but they're going to be
part of the degree program so instead of
trying to develop a completely separate
computer science curriculum what we were
doing is we're introducing those as
courses that you can complete and uh
they're they're going to be the same
content we're just also putting them in
the context of the computer science
degree now you might be asking but it's
an undergraduate in computer science
like
I strongly believe that every computer
science undergrad should learn these
skills in 2022 I mean if you look like
what's happening with you know gpd3 and
in Dolly and like all these other tools
uh stable diffusion things like that
like
it's clear that that's going to be a big
part of working in Tech in the future
just like every like
almost none of the University degree
programs we saw had an Ethics Course
almost none of them had a security
course
I couldn't believe it I couldn't believe
that security wasn't taught like
mandatory for every single undergrad to
like learn information security but it
wasn't so we're stepping in uh with our
very opinionated uh just as Conrad ho
said uh a second ago we are trying to
make sure that people get this even if
you know there's like a lagging
you know computer science curricula
again it takes a while to get a whole
bunch of uh academics to agree and
launching a course and get the
department chair so education is
necessarily kind of slow and that keeps
it from constantly jumping around and
chasing Trends and stuff uh but at the
same time
we we have the ability to say like we
are going to cover a whole lot of
machine learning in this course
or in this degree program a quick fun
fact about
um me and Conrad when we are putting
together in a few questions we actually
used the new GPT chat and we haven't
been you know asking directly what uh
what it because we've been riffing and
having an awesome conversation but the
starting point for a lot of the
questions that we were putting together
beforehand came from that and they're
all like extremely extremely good and
well thought out so it's it's crazy to
see like and that's today and you can
only imagine in three or four years like
what systems like that are going to be
able to do it's it's incredible
um but I had one more question and then
I'll toss back over to Conrad something
that you mentioned before right away was
that
um you know free free code Camp isn't
just you it's this Global community of
people it's now I assume there's a bunch
of full-time staff as well that that
work for you and I'm wondering how that
um you know a little bit selfishly for
myself how you've sort of continue to
scale your impact as you know you have
all these these new initiatives coming
out interested to know it and also maybe
touching on a little bit around the
experience for you transitioning from
just being the person who could make all
the decisions to now having to sort of
again collaborate with people and work
through that process
yeah so we have a team and uh
generally I just delegate like
um for example magesh makes a lot of our
information security decisions and uh
Muhammad makes a lot of our code-based
decisions all over
um Jessica like I I really I just defer
to people who seem to be more passionate
the entire team it's kind of like
everybody just grabs the work that
they're interested in doing and then
they really become familiar with that
area of the code base or that area of uh
you know course creation and things like
that I'm heavily inspired by Valve these
the video game company like they they
kind of did this thing at the time which
was revolutionary where she was like
there's no managers like everybody just
works on what they're interested in and
if they want to get other people to work
on something they have to make a
compelling argument like oh we should
build this and you should come and help
and if they can get people to climb onto
a project then that project is done and
then like the less exciting projects
don't necessarily get done uh but you
know obviously of security and things
like that those may not be as exciting
but they do need to get done right so to
some extent that breaks down and you
have to say like I know you want to be
building this but we really need to like
you know do our you know
uh offset audit or something like that
right
um and then a lot of the the boring
stuff uh like the accounting stuff
um like processing payroll like I've got
like uh I've got all these like free
cocaine shirts down there you might be
able to see the big box those those are
um I've got like this giant box full of
free cocaine shirts and it like there
wasn't anybody clear to like delegate
this to but I wanted to make sure
everybody on the team had at least like
jersey shirts so I I'm mainly taking
these poly
polymailers and like
slapping labels around the world it's
like one of the things that needs to be
done and that wasn't clear who to
delegate that to so uh a part of that is
just being like an extremely low budget
like charity
um we don't have like just tons of money
to like delegate these things like oh
we're gonna get this shipping and
fulfillment like that stuff costs money
and like my time I can just listen to
some music and bag stuff up so a lot of
those decisions are made just kind of
preserving scare stone or fonts
um
yeah I don't know if that 100 answers
your question but a lot of it is just
like
it's it's not we're not thinking on like
an extremely systematic like you know
you how you would Envision like Tim Cook
making decisions about logistics and
stuff like that and like having these
big meetings with all these managers and
like them reporting to their reports or
in the military right like there's not
like some big chain of command it's just
me working alongside these other
developers and instructors around the
world and like trying to help
yeah I love that I think that resembles
the open source community and um yeah in
its entirety
um so uh speaking of uh you know uh like
uh running sort of like a small non-f I
mean small but growing uh non-profit you
know like you just showed us your uh the
t-shirts right uh I think like a really
important part of this is how to
uh hook into the uh you know growth
hacking or like like hook into like an
angle that can help you scale right so
like um I was just wondering you know do
you have any uh like specially for like
other people who also really want to you
know uh build a large community to to do
something impactful right like do you
have any uh advice yeah I have tons of
advice thank you that's a great question
thank you
um first of all make use of big
platforms but don't become too invested
in them obviously you can see the chaos
going on on Twitter it does affect us
like we've got
I don't know like 600 000 or so
followers for free cocaine that we've
worked really hard over you know eight
years to build up that following and to
to only share like the most useful
helpful tweets because we don't want
people to like have second thoughts why
I'm gonna follow on this website you
know
um I personally you know probably spent
like waking months of my life uh
responding to Learners on Twitter and
like encouraging them and doing things
like that right
um and if the platform goes down
tomorrow it's going to be really sad I
don't think it'll go down but the
quality is most likely going to go down
if they get rid of the moderation Staff
and Stuff uh and it just reminds me like
you know you want to kind of surf these
these waves right like maybe this
platform is cresting and you want to go
on that and then you're going to want to
jump off to another wave as this one
declines there like every company is
ultimately going to get acquired by
somebody else
um unless they're a non-profit which
they can't really be acquired except by
another non-profit that's fun fact
um so you don't have to worry about this
happening to free cocaine but you do
have to worry about it happening too I
mean with Tick Tock it's already like
part of a giant corporation uh but
um for example Instagram's a great
example like a lot of people really felt
like this cool Grassroots Community like
oh yeah and then it got bought by
Facebook right and you could argue that
it hasn't gone downhill too much uh but
the the point is like there there's
always going to be like this window of
time where you can strike while the iron
is hot and at some point you're going to
get diminishing returns from that and
you should move on don't tie yourself to
a specific platform this is one of the
reasons like
I I would be very wary of using like sub
stack instead of using my own you know
domain in my own RSS feed and all that
stuff right like uh ultimately open
protocols like email
RSS for podcasts you know blogging
things like that
Google search is just treat it like
another platform we didn't realize that
for a long time today a lot of discovery
of free code Camp as a community comes
from Google is it like probably 10x what
comes from social media so uh just just
keep your eye out on on what platforms
you can leverage but don't ever let the
platform have so much control that it
can determine your destiny just just
treat everything as though it's
eventually going to be bought by Elon
Musk getting burned to the ground
yeah yeah I totally agree uh and uh just
quick thing I would add on to that is
also don't try to build your own
platform if there's an existing one with
uh that you can leverage off of right
you're going there for the audience
you're not going there for the
engineering and stuff
yeah yeah
um I think uh you mentioned a little bit
about open source stuff and I think uh
with that I'll pass it back to Logan who
is a board member of num Focus
yeah I I don't have any specific open
source questions to ask around uh around
that but actually just I think perhaps
the concluding question because I know
we're coming up on time and this has
been this has been awesome Quincy I
think I have I have 20 more questions
just that have spawned from from the
conversation that we've been having but
um what's the thing that you're sort of
most looking forward to in in 2023 as
far as
um you know free code camp and uh the
the courses that are on the horizon or
new new sort of pivots for the for the
organization Oh by far the most thing
I'm most excited about are these
upcoming data science focused university
courses that we're developing uh because
it's just like people always ask for
them and we've been publishing a lot
like I said we got some grants from the
tensorflow team and uh hopefully we'll
get some additional grants from
different uh players in the space
um that are that are creating tooling
around this uh but that's just like the
typical the iceberg like we're going to
produce some really
high quality like end-to-end lecture
series that'll be like 15-20 hours worth
of lectures plus Labs that are probably
going to be on Jupiter notebook plus
exams so it'll really feel like a high
quality move coming from free code cam
now of course if you want some high
quality moocs you know uh the entering
course has been up for quite a while
um there are all these other classic uh
machine learning courses that you can
get and data science courses but
um I would argue that
um
you know
it'll be nice to have one that's
completely free and open it's developed
by the community and that is actively
maintained with interactive components
um so so that's that's the thing I'm the
most excited about probably
I love that no that's uh I'm I'm excited
about it as well and um I I agree with
you it'll be really sad if uh Twitter
disappears because or you know goes more
into chaos because I I think I that's
where I consume most of my free code
Camp
um content and so I'm always so excited
to see a an article pop up my feed and
actually again as another piece of
Praise I think you all do a really nice
job of figuring out like the right
Cadence to release stuff so it's not
overbearing and it's I'm always excited
and have fresh eyes when I when I do see
that content so
um congratulations on on what you've
built it's it's been a tremendous uh
honor for us to have you here to to chat
about free code camping and hopefully
um we'll be able to have you again next
year and we can hear about some updates
and and hear about uh What uh all the
the new Lessons Learned in in 2023 that
are on the horizon
yeah absolutely I hope everybody
watching this I hope you enjoy the
conference and I hope you learned quite
a bit and I hope you're taking notes
um and uh if I could just say parting
like call to action for everybody out
there get involved in the free cocaine
Community again we're like a charity
we're open source we're really just like
what makes free code Camp great is
people like you getting involved
contributing to open source uh if you
are bilingual and want to help us
localize into uh your ancestral tone we
would welcome that help uh and uh just
even hanging out on the Forum and
answering people's questions just uh
anything you want to do to get involved
it's a huge help and of course we're
donor supported charity and uh if if
you're interested in like supporting us
with like just a simple five dollar a
month donation that really does go a
long way every dollar we get from donors
dozens of hours of learning uh are
carried out thanks to each of those
dollars
I love that I've been a donor on on
GitHub for a few months now and it's
it's awesome I think that metric of like
dollars to learner hours is so awesome
and it like it really
um it clicks for me every time I see it
I'm like why would I not want to spend
my money helping people uh be able to
learn the code so
um definitely check it out
freecodecamp.org it's been up on the
screen for a while and and thank you
very much Quincy for for being here and
for sharing with us thank you gentlemen
everybody have fun thank you